Inbar: Okay, thank you
for attending this session.
So how do you like
your new Galaxy Tabs?
So hopefully,
the next thing you want to do,
now that you've
got your device,
is to write Android applications
with that device
that work
with Google APIs.
My goal here is to,
after watching this session,
you should be able
to get started
and be able to build
real applications.
So let me introduce myself.
My name is Yaniv Inbar.
I've worked at Google
for about four and a half years,
and during that time,
I've worked on the Google
API Infrastructure Team.
I am the tech lead of the team
that develops client libraries
for Google APIs,
and also the lead developer
of the Java library.
And one of the key goals
of the Java library
is to make a great experience
for working with
Android applications.
And I'm
really excited here today,
because just about a year ago,
I announced a prototype
of this library.
I gave a quick demo,
working on a G1,
and I talked about
how great this is going to be.
And today,
the big announcement
is beta.
So the Google APIs
client library for Java
is now in beta,
and we're eager to have you
try it and give us feedback
on how it's working for you.
We've written applications
based on this library,
so we feel
pretty confident about it.
So this is our beta period,
and we hope that
if all is successful,
we'll be able
to go out of beta soon.
So this, um, so all the best
practices that we've learned
about accessing Google APIs,
um, we've pretty much codified
in this library.
And I'm not gonna
go through every detail
of what's found
in the library.
It covers a wide range
of use cases,
but I'll cover the highlights,
which are most important to you,
as Android developers.
Before I jump into the library,
I just want a quick idea
of, um, the kind
of experiences you've had.
How many of you have developed
an Android application?
And how many of you,
of those of you,
have developed
an Android application
that works
with Google APIs?
Okay, and how many of you
thought the process was easy?
Okay, no hands are going up.
I didn't think so, either.
And this was a big challenge,
um, so we wanted something
that was really powerful,
really efficient,
but also,
reasonably easy to use,
so you can get started quickly
and in powerful applications.
So let's first talk about
what other platforms
that we're targeting
with this library.
Um, Android, of course,
our premier platform
that we're focusing on today,
but this library also
really works the same way
on Google App Engine,
if you're writing
in a Servlet environment,
or an install application
using Java 5.
All those platforms
are supported,
and that's
important to understand
when you're
using this library,
because that theme
will come often
as you're experiencing
the library.
What are the APIs that
are supported by this library?
Well, of course, Google APIs.
There are actually two different
categories of Google APIs.
I'll go more
into detail about that.
Some are built
on our older technology--
the Google Data API
technology stack.
Um, YouTube, Blogger,
those kinds of APIs,
and some of them are built
on the new infrastructure,
and I'll tell you
about the advantages
of the new infrastructure
and what this means
to you as developers.
But really this library
is designed
for pretty much any API
on the Web.
Why would you care about that
as an Android developer?
Well, why would you want
to use a different library
with one vendor and a different
library for another vendor?
Ideally, you'd like a library
that would pretty much work
with any API and be--
have a consistent experience,
so if you're developing
an Android application,
you'd want to use
the same library.
And what are the data formats
supported by this library?
Well, JSON is
our premier data format.
It's, by far,
the most common on the Web.
It works really great
with JavaScript,
but really to support
across many languages.
It's a lighter weight format
than XML.
XML is a more traditional format
than we've used for any--
for REST APIs.
The Atom Publishing Protocol,
in particular,
is based on XML,
so it has a long history.
And this is also supported
by this library.
We have support
for any kind of media
that you might want
to use--pictures, videos.
I take a photo
on my Android device.
I want to upload it to Picasa.
That should work
with this library.
We really allow you to plug in
any data format that you want,
but also the ones that we've
built a good experience around
with the library.
While authentication mechanism
is supported by the library,
Um, ClientLogin
is the traditional
username/password
authentication mechanism.
Um, it's managed by
the Android operating system.
You use it
with Google data APIs.
But we really support
and recommend OAuth
as an open
authentication protocol
that works across
many different web sites,
and I'll talk more about that.
And this may be the most tricky
part of this presentation,
and maybe the part
I'm most excited about
to talk to you about today.
So let's break this down.
Let's start with the platforms
supported by this library.
If you don't mind, I'll extend
beyond Android for a moment.
So a key design goal
of this library--
we want to make sure that it
will work across any platform
based on Java 5.
So we want to be
platform neutral.
That means we can't take
advantage of maybe some hooks
that are in the Android SDK.
But the advantage of this
is that now we can be sure
that we can work
pretty much the same way.
If you see a library that
was developed for OAuth 2,
you don't have to worry about--
based on this library,
you don't have to worry about,
well, is it gonna work
on AppAge, and is it gonna work
in some other environment?
The library works the same
in all places.
And the only way we were able
to make this happen
is by making
everything pluggable.
I can pick
a different HTTP stack.
I could pick
a different JSON library,
a different XML library.
Authentication--I should be
able to use any one I want.
So that's
a key design principle here.
So let's take a look
at some code, and I'll warn you,
you're gonna see a lot of code
in this presentation.
This is a 201 level session.
I won't be able to go
into all the basic details,
but I really want
to make sure that you see--
you'll be able
to just write some code
directly after watching
this presentation.
So here's what it looks like
on the normal
Java command line application.
It has the main method,
and there's this Buzz object.
This is part
of our generated libraries.
I'll talk more about that,
but I'll point out
one point of confusion
here in this presentation.
If you're an Android developer,
you're very familiar
with activities.
Those are
your main UI components.
Unfortunately, Buzz
also has activities,
so I'll try to make it clear,
based on the context here,
of what I'm talking about,
but basically, Google Buzz--
I hope most of you
are familiar with that.
It allows you
to post your activities.
You can download to
other people's activity stream.
You can make them public.
You can have them shared.
I have an example of someone's
public activity stream.
It's a demo account.
So you call
buzz.activities.list.
It returns an activity feed.
You have to check
for null there,
because there may not be
any public activities
for optimization.
But in any case,
we just iterate over it.
This is just basic Java
programming and print to dot.
So hopefully, really into it,
hopefully, pretty readable.
So let's look at what this
looks like on another platform,
on AppAge.
So I'm extending it
to be Servlet,
and there are
a couple minor differences,
but mostly,
this is the same, right?
So we've got the Buzz object
that manages your--
anytime you're working
with this library.
And again, the code below
is pretty much the same.
So I want to highlight
one really important
difference here, though--
The primary site
passes to the Buzz object.
You'll notice I'm using
a UrlFetch transport.
That's the ideal one to use
when working with Google AppAge,
and it's
only applicable to AppAge.
And I'm using Jackson Factory.
That's based on the popular
Jackson JSON library.
And if you don't mind, I'll skip
back to the previous slide
for a second.
Here, I use
Net HP Transport.
That's based on
Java.net HP URL connection.
So that's the one
that's applicable,
but that's pretty much the only
thing that's changed here.
I'm also using Jackson Factory
in this case.
So if you don't mind,
I'll jump now from App Engine
to our premier platform,
Android.
If you've done
any Android programming,
this is pretty basic
Android activity--
list activity class.
It just gives you a list box
of all the activities
from this person's
public stream.
Nothing new from the perspective
of Android programming.
I am doing some bad things.
Maybe you can notice it
on this slide,
and I'll talk about what's wrong
with this picture.
It works,
but there's some things
that are not quite
the best designed.
So I'm downloading a list
of Buzz activities,
and then I'm converting
each activity content into HTML.
And that actually displays
this nice HTML content.
So pretty simple Android
programming and mostly the same
in terms of look.
I am using the HP URL
connection,
and I'm using
Android JSON Factory.
This is maybe not
well-announced,
but if you look
in the Android SDK,
there's now a JSON library
that's actually streaming.
That's really good, so that's
the one I'm using here.
And I'll talk a little more
about that later.
So let's talk about
the pluggable HTTP stack.
I showed you some examples.
The biggest difference
between them
was which HTTP transport
I used.
UrlFetch Transport, that's the
ideal one to use in App Engine.
If you're programming
for Android,
you have
two important options.
One is based on
HP URL connection, which is--
if you're familiar with
any kind of Java programming,
that's part of Java.
It's part of the Android SDK.
Also, the second option you have
is the Apache transport.
That's based on
the popular Apache HP client.
And that's not part of the Java,
but it is part
of the Android SDK.
At least for now it is.
So the question is, well,
which one should you pick?
The answer
is a little tricky.
I talked to an expert
on the Android team,
and he tried
to explain it to me.
Basically, they fixed
a whole bunch of issues
with the implementation HP URL
connection to Android
in the Gingerbread release.
You may or may not
have encountered those,
but it's best practice
just to use that one.
It's really the one
that they've developed the best,
so highly recommended if you're
targeting Gingerbread or later.
Use that one.
I'm not sure how good
a support they will have
for the Apache HP client
in the future.
They still both work,
but that's what's recommended.
But if you're working with
a previous version
of the Android SDK,
you'll want to still use
the Apache transport,
just to avoid those few bugs
that they fixed
in Gingerbread release.
If you're targeting
both Android SDKs,
I created
a little utility library
just as if Android level,
greater or equal to Gingerbread.
Use one,
also use the other.
Okay.
So let's
talk about the library
and how you make requests.
A lot of times,
every request you make,
you'll do a lot
of the same things.
I want to set
the user agent string to--
this is the application name
I want to set the G data
versus working
with Google Calendar,
you have to specify
what version of the API
you need using a header.
That's something you need to do.
If you're writing
any real application,
you just
have to do those things.
You need to enable Gzip,
if you want the most
efficient posting of content.
So there's an example here
of how to use a request factory.
A request factory is nice,
because it lets you do
a bunch of consistent behaviors
across every request you make.
There's some more sophisticated
functionality in it.
I'm not demonstrating code here,
but you could have code run
before you
execute any requests.
You can have code run after you
get an unsuccessful request.
So why are these in the library?
Well, um, for OAuth
is a great example.
OAuth 1.0, for example, requires
you to sign every request,
so that's how you can
build a hook every time.
Before you execute a request,
you just sign the request using
the OAuth 1.0 specification,
and go ahead
and make your request.
Don't worry, we'll make this
a little bit easier for you.
Stay tuned.
So I wanted to put
this little tip in here.
I don't want to dwell on it,
but if you've done
any kind of programming
with making HTTP requests,
it's really nice
to be able to log
the requests
and the responses that you make.
If you set
the logging level to config,
you'll see those requests.
One thing is I'm not showing
the authorization header.
By default,
it's set to config level.
If you set to all level, it will
show the authorization header.
This is maybe to avoid
some use case, if you, um,
you don't want to log
the most sensitive data.
But the one trick on Android
that's really important
is you need to also
set some property here.
You're not gonna remember
exactly the command to run,
but when you go home
and write in your application,
you can come back
to this slide.
Okay, so let's step away
from, you know, the mechanics
of making HTTP requests
and think a little bit more
of the bigger picture.
How do you actually design
your Android application?
The most important principle
that I hope you remember
is you don't want to make HTTP
requests in the UI thread.
If an HTTP request is fast
and you've got
a fast Wi-Fi connection, great.
But if anything like
the experience here
at this conference--
Wi-Fi is not always fast.
It's not always reliable.
That's the reality you have
to deal with on Android devices.
So don't make any HTTP requests
on the main thread.
That was the mistake I made
in the first sample code
I showed you.
One risk is if the Android
operating system sees, okay,
your application is hanging,
it's not doing anything,
it's gonna put up a dialogue
box, a scary dialogue box,
saying, "Hey, your application
is not responding.
Do you want to shut it down
now?" Okay, that's not good.
So the simplest solution
is to just use AsyncTask,
and I'll give an example
in just a minute.
But before I show you that
example, I highly recommend--
there's a great session
from IO last year,
called "The Beginner's Guide
to Android,"
which really covers this
in detail
and shows you
how to use AsyncTask.
Um...
So here is an example.
Um, I tried to squeeze
all that code into the slide.
I apologize.
Um, but basically, uh, the top
of it is pretty much the same.
I've--I'm extending
list activity
but then I'm using AsyncTask.
I declare a class
called "Load Activities."
And I've got
a progress dialogue.
And it'll show
a nice little circle
saying, "loading your activities
now."
And then this, uh,
this method
called "due in background,"
which, um, Android takes care of
all the thread synchronization
for you,
so if you don't know
a lot about multithreading,
this is a really great tool,
and you don't have to worry
about making sure
that the memory's
properly synchronized.
So it--the implementation here
is pretty simple.
One line of code--
I execute the request
using the library,
and I return the activity feed,
and that activity feed
is passed to...
next slide--
on post execute.
So it takes an activity feed,
um, and pretty much does
the same UI code
that I showed you earlier.
And maybe some of you--
this is boring.
You've already seen this before.
Um, that's great.
If you haven't seen it before,
please try it out.
Um, so that's AsyncTask,
and it's relatively simple.
Um, but let's say
you're building
a-a more complex application.
Um, in my case, you know,
I'm just displaying
a bunch of, um, buzz activities.
Worst-case scenario--
um, I lose those activities.
I can always make another
request and get a new one.
But a lot
of, um, real applications
require you to do something
more sophisticated.
So, um, a better design,
um, that deals with,
uh, more complex use cases
is to actually use
a background service.
And I won't go into details.
Um, there's actually
an excellent session
from last year's Google I/O
that I really enjoyed
that shows you
a lot of the different options
for how you can do this called
"Developing Android
REST client applications."
Um, and, um,
and I'll just summarize,
you know,
the--the general principle,
um, which is, you're going
to have a background service
running on the device.
It's going to store the result
of the HTTP request,
uh, in a SQLite database,
and then it's going to talk
to, uh, the activity
in the U.I. thread,
give it back the response.
But activities
have a life cycle.
There's no guarantee
that, um, that the activity
is going to be there.
Um, when the response--
maybe the user got a phone call,
and, uh, or maybe they want
to play "Angry Birds"...
I'm not sure--
The Android operating system
might decide, "you know what?
"I'm running low on memory.
Let's just shut down
your application."
Whoops. We just lost some data.
This is gonna be especially
crucial in some cases,
so, uh, the key, uh, thing
you need to do
is when the activity
starts up again,
okay, check
if we have any new data,
load it up,
we're good.
So I want to talk about
something that I see often...
[chuckles]
uh, complaints from developers,
You know,
I downloaded this library,
I'm running the device,
and it's 2.3 megabytes--
you know,
my little example here.
Um, something is wrong here,
right?
And why would you take
a 100 kilobyte example
and end up
with a 2 megabyte library?
So there
is something wrong here,
uh, and the trick
is to use ProGuard,
um, or any other tool that--that
shrinks your application size,
but ProGuard
is a particularly good one,
and, um, it has
a good, um, support
in the Android, um, Eclipse
integration,
so that's why we're recommending
that one.
Um, and you'll see
in this very complex graph,
um, you know--
with ProGuard, without,
which would you pick?
123 kilobytes
versus 2.3 megabytes.
So what does ProGuard do?
What's--what's the magic
behind it?
Well, the first thing it does
is strips out any unused code.
All right, so, um, I want to use
this 1 megabyte library,
but I just need this one method.
Is that okay?
Well, normally not,
but when you use ProGuard,
yes, it's okay, because it'll
only include that one method,
not the rest
of the 1 megabyte library,
and it--actually,
that is what we're doing.
We're using Guava,
which is a very large library,
but we're just using a tiny bit
of it.
So it should work,
um, if you set up your ProGuard
configuration file correctly.
Now one more note about ProGuard
is it also does a lot of other
aggressive optimizations.
It changes your class names
to, you know, single letters
and all sorts of crazy stuff.
You can disable that if it's too
aggressive of an optimization.
Really, the crucial thing
is to cut out anything
you're not using.
Um, but you're welcome
to play around with it.
So how do you set it up?
Um, the number one mistake
people make,
um, in setting up the ProGuard
is forgetting
to add this one line
and default the properties file.
Um, I highly recommend
the Eclipse New Project Wizard.
Um, it generates
a ProGuard configuration file
for you
that's actually pretty good.
Um, and it generates
a default of properties file.
Um, you just put in that
one line--proguard.config.
Um, that will tell it
to run ProGuard.
And then I added some more lines
in here.
I'm not gonna go into detail
how they work
and how they're important,
but suffice it to say
you just add these few lines,
and it, um,
they are really crucial
for this library in particular,
uh, not for Android programming
in general,
but for this library,
you absolutely need these.
Um, otherwise, it's just not
going to work properly.
So, uh, when you run
your program in DebugMode,
it will actually be the full
2.3 megabyte, um, application.
That's okay.
Um, but then you want to make
sure you run it
into release mode, and sometimes
people forget to do that.
I've done that often.
Um, you run it in release mode
and see if any bugs happen.
As I said, ProGuard
can be aggressive sometimes,
so make sure that, you know,
the things that, um, you expect
to work are still working.
Um, all right, so...
let's talk about
the next section
of this session.
What APIs are we trying
to support with this library?
Well, my vision is, ideally,
all of them,
so let's talk about them.
Uh, so Google Data APIs
are, by far,
the most mature platform.
Um,
some really popular examples--
YouTube, Calendar,
Blogger, un, the Contacts.
Uh, those are some of the ones
that you'll often,
uh, see being used.
Um, they have, uh...
many years of experience
behind them.
It's a great architecture.
Um, but there are some flaws
in it,
and I'll talk more about
what those issues were.
But first,
one of the main principles
of this platform
is it's a decentralized
architecture.
So YouTube has its own server
running.
Blogger has its own server.
Calendar has its own server.
And they both--all using
the same, you know,
GData library.
But because it's a decentralized
architecture,
we didn't have as much control,
so we added some features
to one.
They weren't always there
in the other.
Um, and that was one
of the problems
that we tried to solve
with the new infrastructure.
Um, another issue
with, um, the Google Data API's
infrastructure
is, um, XML, and that--
it's a great, uh, data format.
Um, it--we were using
the Atom Publishing Protocol.
Uh, it's a standards base.
It uses REST,
um, as its primary principle,
uh, which, if you're not
familiar with that,
that's when you're making
only basic operations--
you create, you update,
you can delete, um, objects,
so very easy to understand.
However, XML is--is a more, um,
heavyweight, um, data format
than say JSON.
So we--we designed
this new format
called--we called it JSON-C.
Um, unfortunately,
it's only read only.
Picasa and YouTube and Calendar
are some of the few APIs
that implement it,
and it's great, but, um, it--
as I said,
decentralized architecture.
We couldn't do it across
all of our APIs.
Um, the authentication mechanism
supported.
I'm gonna go
into a lot more detail,
but a ClientLogin is a great
choice for Android programmers.
It's not such a great choice,
um, for other--other types
of environments.
Um, so OAuth 1.0 and OAuth 2.0
are--are the authentication,
because you'll want to use
any other, uh, platform
for right now.
So we actually have
a Java library
for Google Data APIs,
um, and it's pretty good.
It has a nice XML data model.
I actually had a role in--
in designing that data model,
um, and it--it's code-generated,
actually,
um, but there are a couple
minor issues
that might worry you
as an Android programmer.
Um, one is it only works
the Google Data APIs,
which is okay right now,
but as we, um, Google comes up
with new APIs,
as I said, they're all going on
this new API infrastructure.
So too bad.
And another minor problem--
it doesn't really work well
on Android.
[chuckles]
You'll get an exception
if you try to use it.
Um, and we think
it might be fixed
on Ice Cream Sandwich SDK.
I heard from one
of the Android programmers
they fixed one bug,
but really, uh,
at the heart of the problem
is it really wasn't designed
for Android at the beginning,
from the start.
It's--it's not efficient.
It--it--it doesn't think
about use cases
that you want to think about
as an Android developer,
so we don't recommend it,
um, but yet, it still exists.
It's still maintained.
It still works.
Um, but we haven't touched it
for about two years now.
So let's talk about
the new API infrastructure
and tell you why I'm excited
about--about it,
and--and why I've really focused
all of my energies
to make sure it's really
well supported in this library.
Uh, it's a centralized
architecture--
really important, because we can
roll out new features,
and they work, um,
across all the APIs.
It--we focus on JSON, which
is a lighter weight format.
It's more natural to use.
Um, it's a much more pleasant
experience.
OAuth is our, um, our
authentication mechanism
for almost all of those APIs
that we, uh, that they support
with this--with this platform.
Uh, and some examples--
okay, Buzz, um, Latitude,
Search API forShopping
is a relatively recent one.
You'll see new ones
being rolled out quite--
um, um,
at a reasonable pace now.
Um, so if you want
to get more details,
I highly recommend
two, uh, sessions.
One is a session from last year,
um, called
"How Google Builds APIs."
It really talks about
our new API infrastructure
and the vision
that we had a year ago,
which, thankfully,
hasn't changed at all.
We've just, uh,
simply rolled out on the vision,
executed that vision.
I actually make a quick
appearance on that video.
That's where I talk about
the alpha prototype
of this library.
Um, and the second one
that I highly recommend,
if you're really gonna get
a beginner's view
of working with Google APIs,
I highly recommend "Life
of a Google API Developer."
Unfortunately,
you just missed it,
but when you--when you go home,
um, you know, find it on YouTube
and watch that one.
So Announcing today
the Discovery Service,
and the geek in me
is really excited about this.
This is really cool.
[chuckles]
Uh, we just announced it
on a blog, uh, yesterday.
Um, it's basically a directory
of all the APIs
on the new
Google API infrastructure.
Um, and you get a Discovery
document for every API
that tells you
what other methods are supported
on these A--uh,
by each API,
um, so, um, and what are the--
what's the schema,
the JSON schema of--
of the objects
that are being, um, manipulated
and--by this API.
Um, so you can think
of Buzz activities--
that list, that's the method.
Activities feed--well,
that's your--that's your object.
And also the OAuth 2.0 scopes,
and--and you'll see us
really focusing
OAuth 2.0 as our premier
authentification method.
Um, so there's
a really great session
if you're interested
in this Discovery service--
Uh, "Building Custom Client
Libraries for Google APIs."
I believe
it's tomorrow afternoon.
Uh, check your session guide.
So what can you do
when you have a Discovery API?
Well, the first thing
we thought of
is let's build an API Explorer.
It's a web-based tool,
and I'm gonna brave
and attempt to--to run this
real quick.
Let's see
if I've got the internet here.
Um... okay.
So we have a list
of all the services.
And let's pick Buzz,
activities.list,
and you'll see--
it tells you the description
of everything you need to know
for the userId LPIC.
"At me" for the scope--
Ah, self, that's a good one.
Execute it.
Whoops. I'm not authenticated.
Let's try that again.
I'm authenticated now
apparently.
[chuckles]
Aha! It works.
Um, now why is this useful?
I can see
the authorization header.
I can see exactly the request
it made.
I can see the response.
I can see the data format.
Whoa, there's a lot of data
here.
Wow, I just wanted to check
the activity content.
Okay, here we go.
So here's the activity content.
I'll come back to this
in a second.
Okay, so this is fun.
This is just a great tool
if you're doing
any kind of Android development.
So let's go to the next tool
that we--what--the next thing
we can do with Discovery.
Uh, well, we've got
the APIs console,
and I highly recommend
the session
that, uh, just ended,
uh, momentarily.
Um, this is about setting up,
uh, which APIs
you want to access
as a developer,
uh, based on
this new infrastructure.
Um, it's about getting
your API access key,
which is going to be important
later.
Um, I'm not gonna show you
a demo--
well, I could show you
real quick what it looks like.
Here it is running,
so let's see.
I want to use
the URL Shortener API.
That's a fun API.
Okay, it's on now.
Great.
So I get a free limit
of 1,000 queries per day.
Um, if I go beyond that,
I'll probably have to pay
for that usage,
um, but that's
a pretty high limit.
Um, you can see
I've already enabled Buzz API.
If you go to the API access tab,
you'll actually see
"Get your API Access Key."
And it will look
something like this
with the API key
not blocked out.
[chuckles]
Sorry.
And... so I'll come back
to this,
um, later in the--
in the presentation.
Okay.
So what's the next thing you
can do with the Discovery API?
Well, actually, last year,
immediately after
the Google I/O session,
they had, um, a developer--
I don't know if you're here
in this room now,
but come up to me and say,
"Hey, wouldn't it be great
"if you took
the Discovery API
and generated a bunch of
libraries based on that?"
I said, "You know what?
That's a great idea."
So one year later,
we're proud to announce
we've got generated libraries
based on the Discovery API.
Um, so here's an example
of how you can use it.
Um, I already showed
this earlier.
Google Buzz
getting an activities list.
Um, I have here an example
of inserting an activity.
Um, we've got--so this is based
on the JSON schema.
We can just generate
Java classes right out of it.
So I do new activity,
I set the activity content,
um, and...
I call the Buzz activities
an insert method,
I get a result back.
Pretty straightforward,
pretty readable.
How do you delete an activity?
And I'll give you one hint here.
I always forget to call
a .execute method.
[chuckles]
Um, you--you're calling
that "delete,"
and you think, oh, that's going
to delete my--my activity.
Oh, I forgot to call execute.
So don't forget that.
[chuckles]
Okay, so we've got
generated libraries.
So this is what gets me excited
about this new
API infrastructure.
Uh, we're able to provide this
to you.
It's gonna make your life
a lot easier.
You don't have to write your own
HTTP request intializer
that sets the GData version.
It just works.
All right,
so what are the data formats
supported by this library?
Uh, this is gonna get more
detailed than we've had before.
So JSON--
I talked about how great
of a format that is.
It's lightweight.
Um, it--it's well supported
across different platforms.
Um, but here, again, I'm gonna
give you a bunch of options.
Let's allow you to plug in any
streaming library that you want.
Now why a streaming library?
Why not just use JSON object?
Android devices often have
very low memory,
so what do we do about it?
We can use JSON object.
That's part of the Android SDK.
And that usually works.
The problem is it loads
everything in memory.
You want to avoid that.
Suppose they get that,
um, activities list.
Do you remember how I showed you
that response?
I had to scroll many pages just
to find information I wanted.
So that's gonna be a problem.
You're likely to get
an "out of memory" error.
Whoops.
So the way you solve it
is using a streaming parser.
Um, you're really getting
every little JSON bit,
um, at a time.
Get me the next field,
get me the value,
get me the next object,
so it's a very low level.
It's not that easy to use,
but it's, by far, going
to get you the fastest...
And given that this
is a best practices session,
I want to make sure
you're doing the right thing,
you're building
your applications the right way.
It's your choice.
Do you want ease of use
or, um, and very--
being, you know,
very quick programming
or do you need--you're running,
um, a very critical section
of your application,
and you need that speed?
So, um, regardless,
here are the choices you have
for the JSON library.
You could use Jackson.
Based on our tests,
that, we--we found to be
the fastest choice.
Um, it's based on
the popular Jackson library.
Um, another option is to use
Geggle--Google-Gson,
which we found is pretty fast,
not quite as fast as Jackson,
but--but pretty good,
but it's a lot more
lighter weight.
I think Jackson's somewhere
around 180 kilobytes.
Gson is somewhere around 20?
I don't remember exact numbers,
but that's roughly the scale.
So if you're really counting
every byte,
you might want
to choose Google-Gson.
Um, if you're building
an Android application,
that's probably an important
consideration for you,
uh, a trade-off for you to make.
You choose.
Uh, now, as I mentioned,
on Honeycomb,
and starting
with Honeycomb devices,
they actually have Google-Gson
built it.
It's in
the android.util package.
Um, and if you're writing
an application
that targets Honeycomb anyway,
you might as well use
the Android JSON Factory.
You know, why not just use
something that's part of--
built into the Android SDK?
That's gonna be, uh, definitely
going to minimize your,
um, the size
of your application.
And of course, it's a part
of the Android SDK,
it's probably gonna
get developed in the future,
um, if, you know, if there's
any way to make it faster,
they might do that.
So let's talk about
the data model
that's part of the library.
Um, I talked about
the streaming parser.
Let's talk about data models,
and I'll come back
to the middle later.
So this is a functionality
that's very similar
to other libraries out there.
I don't want to claim this is
the only library that does it.
Jackson has a great, um, object
to JSON mapping,
Google-Gson has one,
and now we do, too.
Um, and the reason
we had to build our own
is because we want it to work
not just with JSON,
we want it to work with XML--
you could do the same thing.
You want to have a data model
for URL query parameters,
for request headers.
You'll see this
across the library
used in
a lot of different contexts.
Well, now let's talk about how
it's used in--with JSON.
So the idea is you have a Java
object, and you have the JSON.
So you want to--every time you
see a Java field of type string,
it maps to a JSON string value.
Um, numbers,
booleans are supported.
You could use enums to map--
to string values in JSON.
You could use
arrays and collection
that maps to JSON arrays.
Um, you can use--if you've got
a JSON object
that can either be mapping
to a Java object
or a Java map.
Um, we--you can use
the full reaches of Java
with this library.
Um, list of activities--
uh, generic types,
pretty convenient.
So I'll give you a handy tip.
When you're getting
to, uh, more sophisticated usage
of the library, sometimes
you only want a few fields,
and you can only declare
those fields,
and it'll basically ignore
everything else.
So I showed you
that long example
of a Buzz activities list.
Well, I just want the content
of the--of the--of the object.
Well, if you only declare
that one field,
it'll basically drop
everything else,
which will make it faster
and use memory more efficiently.
But sometimes
you need to preserve,
um, content that you don't need.
And the reason for that is--
a good example for that
is when you're using
the PUT method.
So the idea is you get
a Buzz activity.
You change one thing about it,
and then you post it back--
you put it back into
the, uh, Buzz activity post.
Um, and the important thing is
if you drop the data
that you don't recognize
or that you're not using,
um, Buzz is going to think,
"Oh, that means he wanted
to delete that data."
Whoops. We can't do that.
So you absolutely
have to preserve everything.
Again, trade-offs--
with the PUT method,
that means that you are keeping
a lot of stuff in memory
or maybe in your database that
you didn't want to preserve.
So those are the decisions
that you would want to make.
Um, and by the way, if you're
using the generated libraries,
we already provide
a full data model for you
that extends,
uh, generic JSON.
So oftentimes,
you won't have to write this,
but if you're really optimizing
for efficiency,
you may want to do
the extra work
of writing your own data model
or if you're working with
something that's not built
on the new
Google API infrastructure.
Okay, so here's an example
of JSON model.
Um, I won't go
into a lot of details into it.
It's hopefully
pretty self-explanatory.
You've got an updated key,
an I.D. key that maps
to update in I.D. fields.
Um, DateTime is something
that's part of the--
of the Java library.
Um, it just represents dates.
You've got
objects within objects.
The key here is the "at key"
annotation.
That's what tells,
uh, the library
to preserve that in a JSON.
So let's talk about how to make
your app more efficient,
not just in terms
of application size,
but let's talk about
the HTTP response size.
So... [chuckles]
you already saw my example
that was 7 kilobyte response.
That's not a great choice.
Again, Android devices, uh,
maybe the user is paying for--
for the amount of data
that they're, um, getting.
Um, but you want to make your--
your application responsive,
so you want to make
the response size small.
A full response, 7 kilobytes--
when you're using Gzip,
it'll be compressed down
to 1.3 kilobytes,
so that's actually
already much better.
Uh, I guess
that's seven times better.
But, um, that's not good enough,
because you're still getting
all of that content.
I really only want
to get the content
of the Buzz activity.
So if I tell to use
just--to--
a special partial response
syntax,
it will just get that one field,
and I'll show that
in the next slide.
But you end up
with a 286-byte response.
That's a lot better.
So order of magnitude difference
just by using it.
The library will automatically
Gzip things for you.
Um, but, uh, the partial
is something
you have to do yourself.
So here's an example
of using partial.
I took that one line of code
that we had used
in many examples before,
and all I did was add
a fields mask.
So request.fields equals
items/objects/content.
Pretty straightforward
in that simple case.
You might have a more
sophisticated use case.
Maybe you want also the updated
and the I.D. fields.
Okay, um, use
a parenthesis syntax,
comma separated.
Uh, not too bad.
It's something
you have to learn,
um, and you'll only
want to use it
when, you know,
you've got a critical section
of your application
that's running slow,
but it's a great tool to have.
So I mentioned earlier,
it's not a good idea
to load everything into memory.
[chuckles]
Um, and I broke that rule,
because now I've got
this activities feed class.
you remember, in my example.
Uh, when I was using AsyncTask,
they returned activity feed,
so, again, I'm making the same
mistake I told you earlier--
don't load everything
into memory.
That's--so that's generally,
uh, a problem.
So how do we find,
uh, a middle ground
between using a stream parser
and using a full model?
So you'll notice here
the one thing
I changed at the top
is I'm using execute unparsed.
So that's gonna return
HTTP response.
and I can just do "get content."
It gives me an input stream.
I parse it using a J--
the JSON stream parser.
I go to data, I go to items,
and then I parse each object
separately.
And I'm doing this--I'm--
I'm parsing the activity class,
so I'm still doing a full
representation of an activity,
but it's a much smaller
representation.
And what I forgot to add in here
is the partial fields mask
to make it
that much more efficient.
All right.
So this is maybe
the best compromise.
Um, if you've got
a critical section,
you want to stream,
um, at the level of entries,
so for each Buzz activity,
parse that one.
So let's jump real quick
to XML.
Now XML is a--is a bit more work
for two reasons.
Um, one is XML namespaces,
uh, and that makes it
more work than JSON.
And the second is we don't
actually provide you
with a data model for, um,
Google APIs built in XML.
So, um, I won't go through
all the details,
but you'll see
the gCal namespace
is in there.
Um, so we have to specify
in the "at key" annotation
this is the XML name
that I want to use.
And another trick here
is the "at type."
That stands for an attribute
that, if you're familiar
with XPath,
you should be very familiar
with this syntax.
And if you--you want
the text content of an XML,
that's text, uh, with open
and closed parenthesis.
So some tips.
Don't forget
the XML namespace dictionary.
Um, you have to declare
the namespace in advance,
and why this is important
is because,
um, if you are serializing
an XML object--
a-a-a Java object
into XML,
you need to know
what the XML namespaces are.
There's that
XMLNS declaration at the top.
So you have to specify them
in advance,
and the library will warn you
if you're not doing that.
Um, you just need to look up
the XML namespace,
uh, uh, declarations.
So how do you get a feed?
So, uh, we provide utility
in the library
that, given a Java object,
will give you that
partial fields mask,
and that works right now
only with the XML.
So you call
GoogleAtom.getfieldsfour.
You give it the feed class,
and it'll just compute it
for you.
Um, you can
also specify yourself.
Sometimes
it doesn't work correctly.
Um, it tries to guess exactly
what your intent was.
If that doesn't work for you,
specify a string directly--
no problem.
I don't want to go
into too many more details.
So what about media?
I get a lot of questions.
"How do I upload, uh, a video?"
"I took a picture.
I want to send it to Picasa.
How do you do that?"
Or I--maybe I want to download
a picture.
So you can use
httprequest.getcontent.
I used that earlier.
That gives you an input string--
pretty straightforward.
Um, and the content type
is the media type.
So how do you upload media?
Well, use input stream content.
That's part of the library also.
Let me show you an example.
It's a little complicated,
and you don't have to understand
all the details,
but, um...
So in this case, um, if you
take a picture with Android,
it starts an intent to say,
"Okay, I want to upload
this picture.
Who can handle this?"
And your activity says,
"I can handle it."
Um, so the user
picks your activity.
And then it goes
to the uncreate method.
You get the intent,
and I'm not gonna go
into too many details here,
but the intent has information
about the URI
for where to download that--
that media from.
From that URI,
we can get a, um,
we can get the content,
the input stream.
We can get the type,
the media type here.
Uh, it's image/jpeg or a video.
And we can get the size
of the content.
So all these pieces
of information,
you put that together,
you send it to the Picasa API.
You set
the appropriate headers.
There's a slug header
in there also.
And you execute the request.
So you have an example
how to do it.
Um, it turns out that there's
one problem with that, though--
because we're posting a huge
media file potentially,
um, this might take a long time.
And there's a protocol called
"resumable upload,"
which I don't have time
to go into here,
but that's something you're
going to want to look into.
That's also supported
by the library,
uh, though not as well
as we--we hoped yet.
Okay, so now from the part
that is maybe the most exciting
of this library...
[chuckles]
and, uh, not quite
completely figured out yet.
So...
the most important thing
you need to know
about authentication on Android
is the AccountManager.
User accounts
are centrally controlled.
You don't want to come up
with your own flow.
I've come up
with a bunch of them myself,
and the Android team told me,
"Don't do that. It's bad.
Don't tell people to do that."
You have to make sure you're
always using AccountManager.
Um, um, um, nice thing
about accounts
is they can be synchronized.
Your GMAIL is downloaded,
sort of happening
in the background.
A lot of cool things you can do
with the AccountManager.
So what is the AccountManager
really? It's an abstraction.
Uh, it has this concept
of an account
and a-a concept of auth token,
but it doesn't really specify
which account that is.
It doesn't work--it works
with Google accounts,
but it'll work with
other kinds of accounts as well.
So the key two things
you need to know--
what is the account type,
and what is the auth token type?
With Google accounts,
the account type
is always com.google,
so that's simple.
The auth token type
depends on
which authentication mechanism
you're using
and which API you're talking to.
And there's a little useful
utility in the library
called Google AccountManager.
All it is is pretty much
the same as an AccountManager
except it knows what
the account type is already.
So ClientLogin--
that's username, password.
It works great
with Google Data APIs,
and, as of right now,
that's the best, um, you have
when you're working
with Google Data APIs.
Biggest problem
with the ClientLogin
for you as a user--
as--as a developer
is it's not supported by the new
Google APIs that are coming out.
Buzz, Latitude--
they're not gonna accept
a ClientLogin token.
Um, but it works great
with YouTube,
Calendar, Blogger.
That's what I'd recommend to use
for them.
Uh, you request permission
from the user.
That's done
by the operating system.
We don't want to see anyone
writing an Android application
that asks the user
for their password.
That's really bad.
Um, who is gonna trust
an application
to give them their password?
So the auth token type
is also called a service name.
If you ever look in
the ClientLogin documentation,
uh, for Google Calendar,
it's called C.L.
Here's an example of what
the user interface looks like.
Um, it says, "Do you want to
give your Google Calendar
access to this application?"
In this case,
it's the calendar sample.
Hopefully, they click "allow."
So here's what it looks like.
Um, this slide
is pretty much the same
as--as the previous slides.
I have to send
a request, um, intializer
that sets the GData version.
The one thing
that's new here is
I'm calling it headers
that set googlelogin.
So the auth token that you got
from the AccountManager,
that's the one you pass
into the header.
I'm using Google AccountManager
class.
I am preserving the auth token
and the account name
in the shared preferences.
That's for convenience.
You don't have to do that.
Um, but it tends to make
for a-a-a more friendly
user interface flow.
Um, I figured if I have
the account by that name,
if there is one, I can just
go ahead and load the calendar,
and that's gonna use a AsyncTask
like I've shown you before.
Um, but if there isn't one,
you call
the Choose Accounts method.
So let's see that one.
Choose Account method uses
my favorite, uh, method
from the AccountManager class.
Get auth token by features.
Now why do I like it so much?
It takes care of a lot of stuff
for you.
If there's no accounts set up,
it'll go through the setup--
a good Google account,
uh, setup floor--flow for you.
Great.
If there is an account
set up already,
or if you--they want
through the flow,
it's gonna put up
that permission dialogue
and hopefully the user
clicks "allow,"
and it will get the auth token
for you.
So all you have to do
as a developer
is implement this
AccountManager feature.
I get the account name
and the auth token,
and I load my calendars.
If there are
multiple accounts set up
on the--on the device,
that method will
only take care of, um,
putting up a dialogue box
that says, okay,
which account
do you want to use?
So very convenient.
Now let's talk about OAuth 2.0.
And I'll warn you
that not everything here
is as pretty
as ClientLogin was
from a developer's
point of view.
But why do we love it
as an authentication mechanism?
It gives the user
a lot more control
over the amount of data
that they give the application.
Um, so one nice thing
about OAuth
is it allows it
to specify a scope of access.
Do I want to give
full read/write access to Buzz--
um, to Buzz, or do I want
to give just read only?
Do I want to give access
only to the photos?
Um, so scopes are
very convenient that way.
Maybe a user's more likely
to use your application
if the permissions
that they have to grant you
are not as, um, scary.
Another thing to know
about auth tokens
is they are temporary.
Um, you don't want to be sharing
your auth tokens, uh,
wile--widely.
and OAuth takes care
of making sure
that those tokens expire.
So an hour later, they won't
work. Users would love this,
because of the security
implications of this.
As a developer, that makes
your life more difficult,
because you have to handle
an expired token.
So how do we do that?
And another important thing--
oh, you check
for 401 error response.
And another important
consideration--
how do we get the auth token
for OAuth 2?
There's nothing
in the documentation.
So what I'm gonna show you
is not documented yet.
This is hot off the press
and not ideal yet.
And the reason we haven't
documented it yet
is because it doesn't work
quite as well
as we'd like it to.
Uh, but I want to show you
long-term this is what you
need to be doing.
Use a special auth token type,
"oauth2:scope."
Sounds simple, right?
It works just like ClientLogin.
The only thing that changed
is the auth token type.
Um, we're gonna improve
on this story later,
but here's how it works
right now.
So the user interface says,
do you want to grant permission
to this application
called "oauth2:" et cetera.
Not the ideal user experience,
so how do we solve that?
Well, we don't have
a great solution yet.
For Google Buzz you can use
a special alias "Google Buzz."
Then it will actually show
Google Buzz
in the permission dialogue.
So that's great for Google Buzz.
It gives you read/write access.
What happens if you want to use
a different API?
Well, we're gonna try to set up
more aliases for you.
That's our quick
and dirty solution.
We'll come up with a better
long-term solution later.
Um, there's another
problem here.
This OAuth 2 flow
gives you anonymous,
unregistered quota,
which for a lot of the new APIs
and basically
the new infrastructure,
that pretty much gives you
nearly zero quota.
It's very small.
I tried it this morning.
I got about ten requests
out of Buzz
before it gave me a 403 error.
"You've made
too many requests today."
Okay, that doesn't work.
So how do you get around this?
Well, remember earlier
I showed you the API's console?
That's why it was so important
that I showed you
that--that--that console
is because you can go
to the API access tab
and get an access key.
That gives you
a very large registered quota.
I think it's about a million
queries per day.
That's definitely something
you can work with
in the bounds of for Buzz.
And for each API it's gonna be
a different story.
So you should be able to use it.
I won't have time
to go through all this code,
but a lot of things
are very similar.
The number one thing I want
to highlight on this slide
is "Buzz at access key equals."
That's what you got
from the API console.
This is a fake one.
And the second thing
you need to know
is you've got another case here.
What happens if you've got
an account but no auth token?
This will likely happen
if your auth token expired.
So here's another slide
that shows you
how to deal with that.
I checked for a 401 error code.
I invalidate the auth token.
That means telling
the AccountManager
the auth token no longer works.
I need a new one.
And you preserve the fact
that you no longer have
an auth token.
and you call
getAuthToken for an account.
You're using
the getAuthToken method
from the AccountManager.
It will give you back
an auth token,
or it will give you
and intent to display
the user permission dialogue.
I'm sorry I don't have to go--
the time to go
through it slowly.
And you call onActivityResult.
You get that token from the--
for the account you have to go
there flow again.
So let me just quickly summarize
what we've talked about.
Um, the new Google API's
client library for Java--
it supports a variety
of platforms.
It supports a variety of APIs.
It supports a variety
of data formats,
um, and a variety
of auth mechanisms.
So in conclusion,
I'm excited to have you
go play with your devices,
build applications.
Try it out.
Give us feedback.
We're now in beta.
Um, we have a developer's guide
that's custom-designed
for Android,
and if you have any questions
or comments,
there's a support page
that links to where
you can give us feedback.
And for this particular session,
um, if you want
to give us feedback,
then there's--
there's a link down there,
and there's some
Twitter hashtags to use.
So that's it, and I'd like
to hear you questions.
[applause]
So we've got
two microphones there.
If there are any live questions,
please come up and--and ask.
And I-I appreciate all of you
staying up here so late,
knowing that lunch is, uh,
competing with the session.
So...
[man speaking indistinctly]
man: So you're talking about
using AccountManager,
but that's only available
with, uh, Android 2.1 and on?
Is that correct?
Inbar: Yes.
man: So what do you do
with devices that are
still running 1.5 and 1.6?
Inbar: Good question.
Um, so the question is--
the AccountManager only works
on Android SDK 2.0 or 2.1
or higher.
What about older SDKs--
um, 1.5, that nice G1 phone?
Um, unfortunately,
there is no
AccountManager there.
It represents a very small
percentage of the user base.
There's actually a great,
you know--
a page on the Android--
on the Android, uh, page
that says what percent of users
are actually on that SDK.
So the one good news
about the story
is long-term this will
work itself out.
Um, but unfortunately, I don't
have a good answer for--
for those earlier SDKs.
Good question.
man: There's a lot of good, uh,
code on the slides.
Are they gonna be
available anywhere?
Inbar: I'm sorry.
Repeat your question.
man: There's a lot of good code
on the slides.
Are they gonna be
available somewhere?
Inbar: Yes, absolutely.
I'll make sure that the PDF
of this, uh, presentation
will be available.
I know there's a lot
of content there.
I don't expect you
to memorize it all.
I just want to make sure
it's available to you
when you need it.
Furthermore, we'll be
providing samples.
We haven't yet published them,
but we will be providing samples
for Android for different APIs
that you can play with.
man: Where should we look to
find the PDF that you publish?
Inbar: Um, good question.
I believe it's on, uh...
When you go
to the Google I/O page,
you'll find it there.
I'm not sure.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Inbar: And the presentations
are going on YouTube.
So if you...
[woman speaking indistinctly]
She says they might be
there tomorrow.
I'm not sure,
but it should be pretty quick.
man: So I have a question
for OAuth 2.
Um, you say the OAuth 2
is not really ready?
So as developers,
should we just wait
until it's pretty mature?
Inbar: Okay, excellent question.
Is OAuth 2 ready
for developers to use?
Um, OAuth 2 in general
is absolutely ready.
We highly recommend, um,
in general,
that developers use it.
The problem is
the OAuth 2 flow in Android
is a problem.
Um, the full story
is not yet figured out.
But what I showed you works.
It's not ideal.
Um, I just wanted to--so--
to let you know what the state
of things are right now.
I don't know what
the right answer for you--
when I talk to some people
on the Android team,
they're working
on different ideas
of how to simplify this flow
and how to make it, um,
a better experience.
Um, I don't know what's coming
in the future,
But I do--
definitely can show you--
This will work, and now it's
the only good option we have
for working with Google Buzz
or any of the new APIs.
man: Okay, so--
so for Honeycomb development,
I think I just leave it
to OAuth for now, right,
not the OAuth 2?
Inbar: Um, well,
it is actually OAuth.
I didn't mention this,
but it works pretty much
the same way as OAuth 2.
The only difference
is you do "oauth:"
instead of "oauth2:,"
but again, it has
the same exact limitations.
Um, it will work.
Um, I'm--I'm eager to get
your feedback
on your experience with it.
man: Thank you.
woman: I have a question
about sort of best practices
for testing with this stuff.
Um, I'm thinking use devices
with smaller amounts of memory
so you find the memory issues
and use a broad variety
of devices.
Would that be your take on this?
Inbar: That's a great answer.
So the question is, um,
how do we test applications
built on this--
uh, on this library?
Um, one idea is to use
a variety of devices
with different form factors.
Um, you want to use
different memory limitations.
Um, you want to make sure
you are using,
you know, different network
connections,
you know, a slow or--
or a flaky connection.
How does it work there?
The error conditions
tend to be the trickiest.
The auth flow tends to be
tricky to get right.
Um, there are--you know,
there's a lot of edge cases
to test here.
Um, we--I wish I had
a more comprehensive answer.
Maybe we should actually
write a, you know,
a good testing guidelines.
That would be
a great idea actually.
Definitely take that.
woman: Okay, thanks.
Inbar: Good feedback. Thanks.
man: Um, for--this all works
with the, uh,
Google documents list API?
Yes?
And then, um, in terms
of authentication,
if the user is using 2-pass
or 2-stage authentication,
is there a best practice
for that? Is that...
Inbar: Okay, so good question.
So the first was do we sup--
uh, the Google documents API--
that's actually
the number one, um, API
that I've gotten requests for,
uh, with this library.
So, yes, it's definitely
supported.
Now the next question was
what happens if you've got
2-, um, 2-factor--
I forget what it's called--
2-step verification set up?
Um, the answer is,
um, different
for older Android SDKs,
as it is with Honeycomb.
So prior to Honeycomb,
you--I'm--I don't think
it worked.
But with Honeycomb it works now,
but it's cleverly hidden
in the user interface.
Um, I just discovered
that recently.
At the very top-right corner,
there's a little button
that says, um, "authenticate
using a web browser"
instead of the "user name,
password" box.
And I think it's only available
on Honeycomb.
I'm not an expert on this topic,
so I'll qualify that statement.
But that was--that's what--
I actually did manage
to get it to work.
I had an account with
2-step authentication set--
verification set up.
I went to the web flow,
and it's the typical,
um, flow--authentication flow
you see in Google.
You click "submit,"
and then it goes back,
and it uses that.
So it--it actually does
run OAuth under the hood,
which is really great,
but it's a very different kind
of OAuth
than the OAuth I'm talking about
in this talk.
man: So for the older APIs,
um, they would just have--
the user would have to get
an application-specific, um...
Inbar: Yes, thank you.
man: whatever.
Inbar: Actually,
I forgot to mention that
that's actually
the most important thing,
getting an application-specific
password.
So the user has to go
through that flow
and type it into their device,
which is not
a pleasant experience,
but fortunately they
only have to do it once.
Thanks for that question.
man: Hi, um, well,
I think my question
is kind of answered
in that previous response.
But basically,
is this library
the libr--is this library
gonna handle, um,
if you want, just general
authentication?
So not necessarily
that I'm using, uh,
Google APIs,
but for example, like, uh,
on, uh, my--
on the web I use,
um, OAuth
for logging--
logging in,
and I make an attribute-exchange
column and stuff like that.
Would that be available
via this library
as far as the information
that you get
from attribute exchange?
Or is it that it's gonna need
to go through the web flow?
Inbar: Um, let me see
if I understand the question,
um, correctly.
So we talked about Google APIs
and the authentication methods
that work with Google APIs,
but suppose you're working
with a different API
with a different
authentication flow.
Does this library support
different authentication flows?
Is that a fair summary or...
man: Um, I guess.
I guess it--it's just using
the Google authentication
without necessarily leveraging
an API, per se,
but just using
Google authentication.
Inbar: Okay. Um, yeah.
So leveraging
Google authentication, um...
yes, so the goal
of this library--
the vision is
you should be able to build
any kind of authentication
mechanism on top if it.
The problem is on Android
we want all authentication flows
to go through
the AccountManager.
So, um, if you don't want to use
the ones that are built in,
um, you'll have to write
your own account, um,
your own account provider
for the, um, AccountManager.
So, um, another company,
uh, might want to provide,
um, account management
for their--
for their, uh,
for their, um...
I'm sorry--
for their accounts.
They'll just set up
an account provider,
an account manager.
And as long as they--
they stick with the idea
of an auth token type
and an account type,
they can implement
the account provider
that gives you an auth token.
And so you can
pretty much implement
any kind of authentication
mechanism
as long as it follows
that abstraction.
man: Okay.
Inbar: Good question.
man: Any status
on Google Cloud Print APIs?
Inbar: I'm sorry, can you
repeat your question, please?
man: Yeah, any status
on Google Cloud Print APIs?
It's not on the list.
Inbar: Uh, I don't know
the answer to your question.
I can follow up, um, later.
Uh, so I don't know
if there's
a Google Cloud Print API.
man: I-I have a question.
Like, if there is
an enterprise app,
and then we test to use
the AccountManager
authentication,
can they leverage
the Google API methods,
or can they extend it
and customize that?
Inbar: I-I'm sorry, can you
repeat your question, please?
man: So, like,
the enterprise app...
[speaking indistinctly]
the authentication mechanism
is different,
it has to go
to the enterprise pack,
and can they use this API
with those apps?
Inbar: Hmm.
I don't know the answer
to your question.
Let me actually, um...
I think we're--
I think we're running
out of time,
so let me meet you in person,
and I'll get more details
from you then.
Thanks for attending.
[applause]